the winner of the one million dollars
and the star of the headline show in las
vegas is
[Applause]
i'm so happy for you guys
uh you just won agt how does it feel
honestly it feels just like the cedar
tree on our beautiful flag we are proud
we are alive and we are just timeless
yes now speaking of the cedar trees i
see it's on your necklace and i saw that
you guys gifted a necklace to sofia
vergara is that right yeah yeah what
does that mean to you
it means like we are blessed to be here
and be able to give
that cedar necklace back to
sofia the one the one who gave us the
golden buzzer the one who i mean helped
the process for us to reach here yeah
how are you guys going to celebrate
tonight
i'm going to eat
we're hungry you saw the work they did
yeah yeah i was so stressed today i
couldn't eat anything really yeah man of
course we had to finish a piece in four
days for the finale
and the girls sacrificed a lot for this
performance
but it was worth it how proud every
second was worth it how proud are you of
them i can't even explain not only proud
like i'm i'm grateful for their trust
because it's not easy at all
for somebody to not see what they're
doing and believe in the vision in front
of them so i owe everything to these
girls i love it are you guys ready to go
to las vegas
we know what hard work is and we're
going to put in all those right now i
got to ask you a million dollars is a
lot of money how will you spend it
the price will be split between the
girls of course and we were trying to
find a space for the girls to train to
have our own space a big space
yeah that's it but it's not about the
money this this is beyond the money now
this is a international thing for us
it's a national pride we gave hope to
our people again yes i love that